The last jedi is a movie that's designed
to subvert audience expectations.
Nowhere is this more evident
than in the way the film handles.
It's three male heroes,
x wing pilot Po Damron
when the gates to him,
Trooper Finn and legendary Jedi Knight,
Luke Skywalker.
Initially,
all three characters seem like they
should fit neatly into familiar archetypes
for men in action adventure films
in Po,
we expect the hot shot fighter pilot who
celebrated for blowing up the bad guys
in Finn,
we expect the noble defector who is
determined to take down an unjust system.
And in Luke we expect the wise warrior
who wields tremendous power in the name
of fighting evil,
but in each case the last jet,
I doesn't deliver on those expectations,
at least not immediately.
Instead,
director Ryan Johnson throws
fans a series of curve balls
over the course of the first act.
Fin reveals his self centered
and defeatist attitude.
Po proves that he's reckless and arrogant
and Luke is so consumed by paralyzing
guilt that he's renounced the
Jetta I and become a hermit.
These unexpected character twists are
part of the reason why some star wars fans
left the theater in a state of shock,
which rapidly mutated into
fits of rage on the Internet.
Now to be clear,
we're not talking about people who just
happen to dislike the last Jetta media
is after all, not a perfect
piece of cinema. No.
We're talking about the subset of mostly
male super fans who felt betrayed and
personally disrespected by
this movie or anything else.
The objections from that
particular group are wide ranging.
The two were accompanied by a girl,
but they often involve an obsessive
level of scrutiny when it comes to female
characters.
On the more extreme end of the spectrum,
band complaints have a tendency to devolve
into wild conspiracy theories about
the Disney corporation pushing an
agenda of forced diversity or feminist
propaganda,
but there is a common thread
running through much of
the backlash that speaks to
an underlying anxiety and anxiety
rooted in deep seated insecurities about
masculinity.
Let me briefly explain
what I mean by that.
Leading men in action adventure
movies are expected to be decisive,
righteous, respected, and to take charge.
In most situations,
men are expected to achieve success by
becoming progressively more and more
powerful as the story unfolds.
This expectation is part of a long
running tradition in Hollywood and the
formula is so entrenched in mass media
that many fans feel aggressively entitled
to seeing that particular version of
manhood reproduced on the big screen,
but as the last gen I begins,
it quickly becomes apparent that this
movie is an interested in catering to a
simple vicarious power fantasy.
All three male heroes are presented as
vulnerable in their fallibility with each
displaying their own set of
rather significant character
flaws and inadequacies.
Now, flawed heroes in and of themselves
aren't all that unusual in speculative
fiction.
In fact,
failure and then learning to overcome
that failure is just the standard recipe
for structuring a basic character arc.
I'd argue the intense fan hate surrounding
the last Jedi has a lot more to do
with the fact that the male heroes in
this movie are directly challenged on
their failures by women.
This is not something
that's supposed to happen.
The space cowboys or space
wizards in Hollywood blockbusters.
Women aren't supposed to interfere
with a man's heroic journey.
So let's dig a little deeper into
the unexpected ways that men are held
accountable for their behavior
in each of the movies.
Three intersecting storylines,
as many critics noted when the
last jet I first hit theaters.
The theme of Women Challenging
Male Bravado is most
evident in the character arc
of Poe.
Damron Po is a hot shot fighter pilot.
He's impulsive,
he is arrogant,
no come back.
And he cares more about being a big
damn hero than he does about effective
strategy or even the
lives of his compatriots.
The Gung Ho rebel pilot is a familiar
archetype and star wars media.
And as a result, we think we
know how it's going to play out.
Audiences expect the good guys to bring
down the enemy death machine in a giant
ball of fire.
And we expect to revel in
the joyful spectacle of
impossible explosions in outer
space.
Dread not down,
but instead of framing pose,
raid on the dreadnought
as cause for celebration,
the movie suddenly pulls
the rug out from under us.
You're demoted, what weight?
We took down, a dread not cost.
There are things that you
cannot solve like Joffrey,
excellent and blowing something up.
We'll learn.
Po is rebuked for his apparent victory
and by extension the audience has rebuked
for enjoying the fireworks.
Those explosions that we were taking
such pleasure in just moments ago are
abruptly reframed as cause
for self reflection and
sadness and we find ourselves
suddenly confronted with a
narrative about consequences
for some star wars fans.
It must've felt as if Princess Leia had
just reached out of the movie screen and
personally slapped them across the face.
Yes.
Now it's noteworthy that blowing up the
space fascist death ray isn't framed as
morally wrong.
Instead we're asked to consider
the tactical and human cost of that
violence.
If ever a beloved leader is incapacitated,
we expect our brash hero to
suddenly find themselves in command,
but that doesn't happen either.
The chain of command is clear
as to who should take her place.
Vice Admiral Hodo off the cruise and
then Vice Admiral Geraldo is even less
sympathetic to pose attitude.
Then general layer.
I've dealt with plenty of trigger happy
fly boys like you. You're impulsive,
dangerous,
and the last thing we need right now,
she harshly chastises Po
for his recklessness and
rightly dismisses his antics
as a liability to their mission.
And this is really what's at the heart
of why so many angry fans tend to hate
vice admiral holdovers characters so much.
That's what's got,
that's what you brought us too.
Get this man off Matt Rich Po Damron
story is that of a cocky,
headstrong,
never tell me the odd style male
hero who is repeatedly reprimanded.
You have bet the survival
of the resistance on bad
odds and put us all at risk
until he finally learns to listen to
and trust women in positions of power.
Okay,
as episode eight begins,
Finn is a man obsessed.
He wants nothing more than find his friend
Ray and then get as far away from the
war as he possibly can.
Fins intentions are selfish
and driven by a lack of faith.
He's convinced that the fight against
the first order is a lost cause.
Sorry if this fleet is doom did. If my
friend comes back to what she's doing too.
Enter rose Tyco,
a low ranking maintenance
worker who's a fan of fins,
exploits from the force awakens.
Got To get back to what I was doing.
So what were you doing when she
realizes he's not really the commitment
resistance hero that she's heard stories
about her disappointment is palpable.
Rose takes on the role of fins,
guide and mentor.
Hold on, come on. Look at this whole
place is beautiful. I need, come on.
Why do you hate it so much?
Look closer.
She is the one who pulls back the curtain
to expose the oppression festering
just below the surface of the galaxy.
And who do you think these people are?
There's only one business in the
galaxy that'll get you this rich
unlike layer and Holdco.
Rose holds no formal position of power,
but she does speak from a
position of moral authority.
I wish I could put my fist through
this whole lousy, beautiful town.
She articulates the political and moral
reasons why the resistance is necessary.
And in doing so,
she inspires Finn to finally
identify as a rebel voice.
God
rebel scope.
And it's her role as moral compass to
both Finn and to the audience that's
responsible for a good portion of the
rage directed at Rose's character from the
more toxic side of star wars fandom.
Many of these guys can't help but view
a woman who is serving as teacher to a
male hero as anything other than preachy,
annoying or emasculating.
Are you kidding me?
The fact that rose also happens to
be played by an actress of color only
magnifies their anger.
The other reason for the backlash against
rose is because she interrupts fins.
Big heroic sacrifice during
the film's final battle,
Faena embarks on a self
destructive charge.
His heart is finally in the right place,
but his judgment is clouded by his
eagerness to act on his new found
convictions.
Has the movie,
makes clear fins a suicide attack
is doomed to fail hotels him.
So
it's a suicide rose tells him so.
And we see
Hanes rickety air speeder
falling apart around him.
But Finn is so focused on striking a blow
against the first order that he can't
see how ineffective this strategy,
understanding that his
action amounts to a noble.
But senseless sacrifice rose steps
in to save Finn from himself.
The heroic sacrifice is part
of a long tradition in media.
We're in death is framed as a way
for men to prove their bravery,
their convictions.
They are love and even their manhood
and movies tend to romanticize images
of men going out in a blaze of glory.
Yeah.
Even when their sacrifice is senseless,
ineffective or unnecessary.
This notion that death and
violent death in particular,
his redemptive or restorative for men is
so deeply ingrained in media that many
angry fans are adamant that fins misguided
kamikaze attack would have succeeded
despite the film explicitly
telling us otherwise.
These fans are incensed that a woman got
the big damn hero moment and she got it
in their view by robbing a male
hero of his chance at martyrdom.
Why would you stop me?
I saved you
when ray finally meets her hero.
The legendary did I night
isn't at all what she expected.
Luke Skywalker has become
a cynical old hermit,
a man so consumed by fear and guilt that
he's turned his back on the resistance
and closed himself off to the force.
Needless to say,
this comes as a tremendous shock
both to ray and to the audience.
Go Away.
Like Ray,
many star wars fans were expecting loop
to appear as a triumph and bad ass.
The one they remember or rather
misremember from the original trilogy.
The thing is, Luke was never really
depicted as a great [inaudible].
Hod Did you read my light saber?
Yeah.
When Luke says this,
seek what?
I'm going to walk out with a laser sword
and face down the whole first quarter.
His words are a reaction
to raise assumptions,
but those lines can also be read
as a response to fan expectations.
As I mentioned earlier, it's assumed
that Hollywood heroes, especially men,
will grow exponentially
more powerful over time.
The expectation is that once a
man has conquered his demons,
those demons will stay forever.
But even though Luke rejected the
dark side back in return of the Jedi,
I'll never turned to the dark side.
His struggle to resist the temptation
of absolute power isn't over for the
briefest moment of pure instinct.
All I could stop it and he's still scared
of the darkness hiding inside himself
just as he was as a young
man back on Diggaba.
Although this older version of Luke
Skywalker is consistent with his
characterization from
the original trilogy,
angry fans still believe that the last
Jedi represents a downgrading of his
power and his status.
I didn't see you.
The fan fury is exacerbated
by the fact that it's a young,
untrained female Jedi [inaudible].
I just feel so full from the fools
who challenges this mythic hero on his
failures.
Not only does this young woman
reprimand the Great Luke Skywalker,
I sent me here with a hope. If she
was wrong, she deserves to know why
we will do.
She directly confronts him and inspires
him to reconnect with the force
later on.
Yoda offers guidance too,
but it's a ray who opens the door for
Luke to overcome his paralyzing self
doubt.
Now
reach out.
So instead of seeing the old Jedi master
teaching ray how to wield the awesome
power of the force,
I feel something audiences are treated
to scenes in which ray reminds Luke what
it means to be a Jedi galaxy
may need a legend. Of course,
ray isn't a more powerful Jedi than Luke
and she ends up being wrong about her
ability to fix Kylo Ren,
but she does possess
something that he's lost.
Ray still has hope.
She still has conviction,
and she's still has clarity of purpose.
The idea that a young woman like ray
would have something important to teach an
older mythic male hero like Luke Skywalker
is a Roni Asley viewed by some male
fans as emasculating.
Yeah,
it's worth pointing out that angry fan
defensiveness isn't necessarily just a
reaction to women existing in
popular science fiction stories.
If women are included alongside male
heroes in a way that doesn't overshadow
upstage or interfere with traditional
expressions of masculinity,
let's get one thing straight.
I'm in charge out here and
you do everything I say
exactly as I say, just relax.
Then we don't see these same kind
of temper tantrums for male fans,
especially if the female characters
in question are cast as young,
white and conventionally attractive.
The last Jed, I isn't satisfied
with simply including women.
It goes much further and puts female
characters in positions of institutional
power or moral authority over male heroes.
The movie then has those women leverage
that power to challenge and ultimately
forced change in men's behavior
and that is almost unheard of in a major
blockbuster film in the end are three
male heroes face up to their
mistakes and overcome their failures.
Ho learns from Leah and Holdco to put
aside his desire for heroic short term
gains. Let's go wait, wait, and
instead consider the bigger picture.
It's only through Rose's moral insights
that fin comes to believe in something
bigger than himself and ray succeeds in
inspiring Luke to be the best version of
himself again and ultimately to do the
exact thing he mocked her for earlier in
the film.
Luke does indeed end up walking out with
a laser sword and facing down the whole
first order.
Yeah.
Despite what the reactionary
conspiracy theorists claim.
This is not an agenda of
masculine inferiority.
Women in the last Jedi hold their
male counterparts accountable,
not out of animosity, but because
they genuinely care about them.
I like it.
Male heroes are not being diminished
or erased in this movie. In fact,
a lot of time and effort is devoted
to giving men transformative arcs.
The last Gen I is a story about men
learning to trust women's ideas and
decisions and then becoming better
people and better heroes because of it.
And while that might be an unexpected
message for a star wars story,
it's a vital lesson that men need to learn
if we are to achieve gender equality.
Thanks for watching these video essays.
Take a ridiculous amount of time
to write, edit, and produce.
So if you'd like to see more of them,
please consider going over to Patrion
and helping to fund my project there.
There's also a link to paypal in the
description below. In the coming months,
I'll be working on a few new video essays,
one of them on gun culture,
media and masculinity,
and another one on the ways that sexual
assault against men is often played for
comedy in Hollywood.
So until then,
thank you all so much for
your continued support.